seven-time nominee you're back again
tonight for actor in a leading role for
the power of the dog
you just hit me with that i yeah that's
amazing i didn't i didn't i hadn't done
the counting that means your peers love
you well
you know this is the biggest thing about
tonight is or this afternoon or whatever
time we're in i've just got from england
so it's i don't know it's breakfast time
right now for me i i
you can't really get higher praise than
from your own peers and to be included
uh as as worthy of being in a list of
top performances this year and what are
this it is really great it's amazing and
then to have this tonight tomorrow
you're getting a star on the hollywood
market i know i know i know a lot a lot
in 24 hours but um
i just got to take it and you know that
means a great deal to me it's kind of
crazy and it's it's a very un-english
thing so i don't know quite what it's
going to feel like going through it but
um i'm excited i'm really excited is it
true that you initially thought
spider-man no way home might not be a
hit no what is that no i think what this
is sort of blown out of the thing where
i have a conversation with kevin feige
and he was like do you realize this is
kind of like the future of cinema in
this period of streaming and covert etc
i was like that's a little bit
exaggerated and he went there's no
streaming service and sony and i don't
you know that i just go oh oh yeah
you're right so everything kind of
hinges on what kind of box office it
does and listen i had confidence i think
as everyone did involved that it was a
terrific script it was a really great
story and the talent involved especially
the three juvenile leads it's just so so
so so good and
the secret that now is all known i mean
it's a killer and
i was just like wow i can't believe i'm
a part of this you know great and i knew
i knew it was going to do well i had no
idea how finally dr strange is coming
back it is conspiracy theorists are out
there there's a lot that they think yeah
they're saying maybe
he's evil
part of the illuminati
i'm just trying to pull faces as clues
that will then be churned over on the
internet
no i like yeah maybe who knows who knows
i don't do
you know it's the beginning of all of
this isn't it and it's weird i i um
i kind of escaped it was spiderman
because we were doing reshoots for
strange i couldn't do the tour so
poor tom and z and jacob and everyone
else had to go yeah uh no no yeah no i
haven't heard about that i mean yeah and
just sort of deny everything okay so i'm
i'm gonna start doing that same game
again
listen i will tell you this it is
it's a feast
it's a sam rainey special and it's uh
it's got everything it says in the title
and a lot more besides
[Music]